hi guys kind of hard to follow that one
but we're gonna actually change the pace
a little bit I'm June I would work at
Manduca which is a yoga company actually
and we're gonna do a little bit of yoga
right now so I want everyone to sit and
close your eyes if it's okay if if
you're not comfortable it's okay you can
leave them open you can place your hand
right hand on your chest and left hand
on your stomach again if you don't feel
comfortable you can leave them however
you'd like and we're just going to take
a moment this moment for ourselves
we'll take a deep breath in and exhale
another deep breath in this time exhale
with your mouth and some of you are
doing it already we're gonna X inhale
and then exhale so that it's audible
alright so I think you guys are maybe
now ready for my story so I had a really
difficult time actually preparing for
this because I was trying to avoid the
stereotypical oh I live in a patriarchal
society or like oh I'm an immigrant and
I moved from wherever but you know when
you tell yourself not to think about
certain things that's all you think
about so those are exactly the two
things I'm gonna talk about today and I
don't really have a cool aha moment
where it's struck and where I was like
you know what this is where I got my
life figured out and the truth is I'm
still trying to figure it out and I
think many of us still are
and so my story's gonna be more about
how I got here and how it's okay to be
lost and how it's okay to wander so I
was born in Seoul and yes it's a well
still
but at the time was was very male
dominant and my mom stayed at home and
my dad worked so as you can see it's a
very patriarchal society and my parents
did a good job though of trying to raise
me a very independent strong woman and
so instead of joining girl scout I was
in a space explorer when other people
were doing dance or whatnot I played
chess I was I was really into math and
science I was a pretty nerdy kid and
when I was nine my family decided that
we were gonna move to Arcadia which is
about 20-ish miles northeast of here so
I moved here and thinking this is so
great land of equality land of freedom
you know I get I get to be I get to be
like one of the boys whatever and so I
get here and one of the first
experiences I have I decided that I
wanted to join Little League I'm a huge
baseball fan and it was I was gonna be a
MLB pitcher when I grew up so I yeah I
just moved here there was a little booth
in front of a grocery store and I walked
up and said I'm gonna join Little League
they're like yo are not joining Little
League and I said why not and like well
girls pay softball here
I said what's softball I only watch
baseball and and and for two days
straight I cried because I didn't let me
join Little League so it was a very
disappointing moment I moved here
thinking that you know everything was
gonna be great and then I got turned
down can't play baseball so that kind of
made me work even harder to compete with
the boys and and be one of them at one
point I even had a bowl cut glasses and
it was a total tomboy I was you know I
was a late bloomer
[Laughter]
and so that path continued on when my
friends were joining dance or drill team
I tried out to be drum major of a
marching band
yeah actually that that for many years
still teach marching yeah
and and I I finally got I told you I was
a late bloomer I finally got to college
and I was like you know what I don't
think people like me you know I like I
saw all these pretty girls in sorties
and I was like oh wait maybe I want to
be one of like you know one of them and
that's what I did I I stopped really
caring about my academic work I stopped
I I stopped I actually quit marching
band and and I said I was gonna be in
this then I'm gonna be in the sorority
um and and I'm it was a great experience
I one of my best friends who's here
tonight here and and so I'm not saying
that joining us already is a bad thing
but it's just it took my focus off of
many things that were important to me
and I really only cared about my
appearance and how I looked and if I was
liked and when I graduated from college
I was really lost because everything
that I had focused on before I kind of
threw out the door and so I started
practicing yoga trying to find clarity
trying to find the meaning of life and
what am I gonna do next so I'm in a yoga
studio and practicing and not finding
clarity not peaceful at all but I keep
seeing these little red frogs on
everyone's mats and like what is going
on what are these red frogs so I I
google and said what is this brand
called Manduca and I found out it's a
little yoga company that's based in El
Segundo and I was like you know what I
don't know what I'm gonna do with my
life anyway what the heck I'm gonna
apply for a job here so I applied for a
job that was seven eight years ago
almost and I interviewed with the CEO at
the time sky melter and I said hey would
would love to join your company I
started doing yoga a big fan of your
brand and I'm looking for a part-time
role I don't really know what I'm gonna
do
and he said Jun you're not gonna work
part-time here you're gonna work
full-time
I know exactly what you're gonna do and
at the time they didn't have an
international division so he decided
that for whatever reason I would be a
good fit for the role and because
because of his trust and and confidence
in me it really instilled this
accountability and responsibility and I
said you know what I'm gonna make this
happen
and and so I did and so for the next
seven and a half years and even to this
afternoon I've been busting my butt and
trying to make this International
Business Forum and uka happen and
meanwhile I had really great mentors
female mentors actually our president
now at the at the moment is also a
female who have guided me along the way
and it's motivated me to get my MBA
motivated me to find a couple different
companies on my own on the side one of
them which is a non-profit and another
consulting business and so the moral of
my story is it's okay to be lost it's
okay to try out different things but
don't ever focus on what people perceive
of you or what you feel like you have to
be because of what society tells you
it's okay to be lost try it out but keep
finding yourself keep searching and
it'll work out
[Applause]
you